I think Bram Rhino gets it done I really
do now that's saying a lot because
pantosia the one thing that bothers me
on this fight is Moreno does when he's
in scrambled stuff he gives up his back
a lot and Pantoja with his Jiu Jitsu how
good he is on the ground if he even has
a glimpse to get hold of Moreno's not
get this one's over and you have a new
world champion from Brazil right but I
think Bram Rayna knows that but it's not
so crazy to say that Saturday night
you'll see 290 could be an awful night
if you're Mexican for my wife or family
don't tell them this but it could be a
tough night like panto's just no [__]
punk man this isn't a walk in the park
it's probably gonna go all five rounds
it could be super controversial too like
it they match up very well with each
other then yeah Rodriguez and Alex
volkanovsky in the main event again
could be a tough night for Mexican fans
tough tough night very tough night you
have two mechs and lose their belt